i have full coverage on my youtube  channel of all of the different ways  other than dealing with guns that  republicans want to solve the problem of  school shooting some of them say we need  more god we need more prayer now to them  i would say why not pray to prevent the  shootings if you pray after the  shootings why not pray before and  prevent the shootings in the first place  they are saying we've got to deal with  mental health well sure i'm always up  with dealing with mental health but none  of them are actually proposing ways to  make mental health services more  affordable and more accessible in fact  the republican congressman gonzales tony  gonzalez who represents uvalde texas  where the shooting took place  multiple times in 2019 and 2020 voted  against more funding for health care  which would include mental health care  these people are pathetic